JENNY MURPHY: Hi, everyone.
Welcome to this week's session
of the Google+ Platform Office
Hours, the show where we keep
you up to date on what's new
in the Google+ platform and
field your questions and take
your comments about the
Google+ platform.
This week, we're going to be
talking about the Google+
History API again.
Specifically, I'm going to give
you a brief overview of
what it is, how it works, show
you it in action in PHP, and
show you something new that
we just brewed up.
So before we dig into the
content, let's do some
introductions.
I'll start because I'm
already talking.
Hi, I'm Jenny Murphy.
I'm a developer programs
engineer here at Google, and I
focus on the Google+ platform,
which means I help you build
cool stuff with the
Google+ APIs.
And next to me in the studio--
GUS CLASS: Hi, I'm Gus Class,
and I'm a developer advocate
on Jenny's team.
And I actually am focused
as well on the
Google+ History API.
JENNY MURPHY: Great.
And through the magic of
cyberspace, a few people are
joining us through
the Hangouts.
So why don't you tell us a
little bit about yourself,
starting with you, Abraham.
ABRAHAM: Hi.
I'm a co-founder of a
new start up called
[? Advocate. ?]
And I've been an active user of
Google+ since the beginning.
And I've been having fun
playing around with the
History API recently.
JENNY MURPHY: Great.
And how about you next, Allen.
ALLEN FIRSTENBERG: I'm
Allen Firstenberg.
I'm an independent developer
and consultant.
I mostly do work with
the Hangout API.
And I've started to dabble
a little bit
with the History API.
JENNY MURPHY: Fraser?
FRASER CAIN: Hi, my name
is Fraser Cain.
I am the publisher of
Universe Today.
And we've been doing a lot of
stuff with the Hangouts and
the Hangouts API.
JENNY MURPHY: Great.
And last, but definitely
not least, Gerwin.
GERWIN STURM: Hi, I am
Gerwin from Austria.
So I've been doing lots of
different stuff with the
Google+ APIs.
And I've been playing
quite a bit with
the History API lately.
JENNY MURPHY: Great.
So we'll be moving back
for questions and
comments from everyone.
But without further ado, I'm
going to tell you a little bit
about the History API, which
we've discussed before.
But I'll give you a quick
rundown before I show you the
PHP code just in case you
haven't heard of it before.
So switching over to
my screen share.
GUS CLASS: And I'll
just fire you up.
Here we go.
JENNY MURPHY: There we go.
So widen it.
It doesn't actually
help very much.
So the Google+ History API.
What is it?
It is kind of like the instant
upload feature that you may
have used on your cell
phone with Google+.
The way instant upload works is
as you are hanging out and
taking photos with your phone
at some exciting party or
event you're at, the photos
are automatically getting
uploaded into a temporary
place that
only you can access.
So that later, when you're in a
sharing mood, you can return
and select which photos you want
to share, and share them
with the right people.
The History API is kind
of like that.
But it's not just
for pictures.
It's for everything.
And it's not just for
Google+ mobile app.
It's for whatever your
application is.
So the way it works is your
users are using your
application.
As they're using your
application, no
matter what it is--
whether it's an application that
tracks your movements as
you hike, whether it's a music
application that you listen to
songs on, or even a blogging
platform, anything--
different moments happen that
make up your user's experience
on that application.
For example, the hiking
application--
finding a trail, starting a
hike, finding a landmark.
As your user uses your
application and those moments
happen, you write moments to
Google in the background using
the History API.
Then later, when your user
finishes using your
application--
they finish their game, their
hike is over, and they've
returned home--
and they're in a sharing mood,
they can go into their history
on Google+, select the moments
that are most important to
them, and they think their
friends would be most
interested in--
like maybe finding a really cool
waterfall on their hike--
and then share them with
the right people.
Because maybe some of their
friends don't like waterfalls.
Only their waterfall circle,
for example.
And that's what the
History API does.
It allows your users to share
their moments on your
application with the right
people at the right time.
But how does it work
in practice?
Let's find out.
The History API is made
up of a few pieces.
There's obviously your
application, which here is a
website, just for
an example case.
There's Google, which hosts
the History API.
And then there's the target.
The target is a little bit
special to this API.
The target is a publicly
accessible web page that
represents whatever the target
of that moment is.
So in the case of the previous
example where I was talking
about a hiking application,
the target might be a page
that describes the place you're
having a hike, or
describes the landmarks that
you may find along the way.
When your application detects
that a moment has occurred--
in the hiking example, I've
arrived at the trail--
it would send a moment
to Google.
It would insert it using a JSON
REST API, very similar to
a lot of APIs at Google and a
lot of the other Google+ APIs.
And then what Google will do
is we will fetch the target
page that you refer
to in that moment.
So the page that represents
that trail.
And we'll go there, and we'll
look for schema.org markup,
which you may already have from
the Plus button or from
web search or for a
lot of reasons.
It will extract all the details
we can from that page
and use that to try and make the
moments in Google+ as rich
as possible.
So that is the History
API, what it
does, and how it works.
So let's dive into some code,
because that's what you're
here for, right?
And we've talked about the
History API a little.
And we've shown it to you in
JavaScript, and we've shown it
to you in Python.
Today, I'm going to show you
how do use it in PHP.
So let's take a look at what
we are about to build.
So switching over my
screen sharing.
So if you have developed on--
make that a little wider.
If you have developed with PHP
on Google+, this probably
looks pretty familiar.
This is the Google+ starter
application for PHP.
It's a very simple application
that shows you the best
practices for developing on
the Google+ platform.
And what I've done is I've
added a little "Write a
moment" button to the top.
It's a very simple
implementation.
All it does is just
write one moment.
And I'll show you the code
that powers that.
So let me shrink this window a
little bit so you can see a
little more clearly.
So this is the code for the PHP
starter application with a
few little enhancements added.
So what have I added?
The first thing I've added
is I've added a special,
generated library that the
PHP client library uses.
This is designed to make
it a little bit
easier to use the APIs.
It's just some convenience
methods that show you all the
different methods that
each API has.
The History API is still in
developer preview, though.
So the generated PHP helper
functions are not part of the
core PHP library yet.
But that doesn't
mean we haven't
started preparing them.
So what I did is I went to the
source code tree, and I went
to the trunk, and I pulled out
the generated convenience
class, the helper functions
for the PHP library, for
History API.
It's called the API [? plus ?]
moment service.
And we'll be using this further
down in the code.
So what else did I have to do?
I had to create a
service object.
This is the implementation of
that class that I included
above, that helper class.
We already have one
for the Plus API.
So just below it, I did the
exact same syntax except for
the History API.
And now, my PHP starter app can
start to make calls to the
History API as well as calls to
the regular Google+ APIs.
So let's go look at the
next change I made.
And here's the meat of it.
Writing a moment.
And this is just
how easy it is.
So in a few lines of code-- so
what I'm doing here is, in my
application, I have a little
button that I press that
indicates that it's time
to write a moment.
I'm using a hidden field that
indicates that a moment is
being written.
And then I'm writing a moment.
And it's actually one line
down here that's actually
doing the moment insert, and
a few lines that build that
moment object.
So what I did is I just took one
of the examples from the
Google+ History API starter,
and I reformatted
it to work in PHP.
So you can see here that the
target URL is specified.
I picked the macaron, one of my
favorite target URLs from
my example code, Baking
Disasters.
And I'm using an add
activity straight
from the History examples.
And I'm setting that target.
So it's a little bit different
than the JavaScript and Python
libraries because they just
specify the request body as a
big blob of JSON.
In PHP, I have to build
it using PHP.
It's just different styles, but
pretty straightforward.
And one other line there,
the start date.
I'll be talking a little bit
more about this once I show
you the software in action.
But here's the write method.
So all it is doing is it's
calling the History service
object that we created
on the Moments API
using the Insert method.
I'm specifying that I'm
inserting a moment for myself.
And I'm writing it to the vault,
which is where all
moments go right now.
And then I'm specifying
the request body.
Pretty straightforward.
Any response is going to
come back into the
right moment's variable.
But I'm not doing anything
with it right now.
I'm just dropping it on the
floor because I wanted a
really simple implementation.
And there's one other change
down here that
ties everything together.
Further down in the project is
the HTML code that you see on
the screen.
And here's the HTML that I
added, which ties it all
together and allows me to
trigger that moment right.
I have a hidden field that sets
a moment property, or
moment POST parameter to the
value true, just so I know I'm
writing a moment, and then
a Submit button.
Dead simple.
So let's see it in action.
GUS CLASS: And so Jenny, so a
lot of this code is just kind
of part of the boilerplate
starter project.
You didn't have to completely
start from scratch, right?
JENNY MURPHY: That is correct.
So what I did is I took the
PHP starter project for
Google+ and just added a few
lines of code, because the
History API is just like a lot
of the other APIs that we
already have for the
Google+ platform.
GUS CLASS: And so
that's awesome.
If you're a PHP developer,
there's a lot of code that's
already out there that we
created to make it a lot
easier for you to get started.
JENNY MURPHY: Yep.
So you only have to add
a few lines to use it.
So let's see it in action.
So I'm hitting the
Submit button.
And we see that it finished
to submitting it.
And the page reloaded.
Because I didn't actually
implement any code that did
show as a success, we're going
to have to go look in the
Google+ History.
And let's go back.
There's actually some little
trick I did back there.
I actually inserted this moment
for a historical thing
I did, because I didn't bake the
macaron today, right now.
I actually baked it in June in
2010, long before the History
API even existed.
So here we see that the
moment got written.
And let me show you how I
did that little trick.
It's a new feature
that we're just
starting to support today.
GUS CLASS: It's awesome,
by the way.
It's very cool to see that you
can get historical data back
into your history.
JENNY MURPHY: Yes.
It's pretty exciting.
It's something that we've heard
a lot of requests for.
And we're starting to
support it today.
So you can see this one line
here that I kind of glossed
over before.
Moment arrow, set start date.
So if you've been playing with
the History API, you may have
noticed that when you insert a
moment, the response object,
when you set the debug flag to
true, contains a start date at
the root of the moment.
Well, you can write to
this field now also.
So for all those historical
moments, for all those moments
that happened before your user
authenticated your app with
Google, or before Google+
History existed, you can now
write using the API so that
they can share those
historical moments also.
GUS CLASS: So this'll be awesome
for all those people
who want to bring in all their
old data into the History UI.
So it's very exciting.
JENNY MURPHY: Yes.
So this is the first feature
that we've added in response
to all of your requests
out there.
Cool.
So that is what I had
to show you today.
How easy it is to get started
with the PHP and the History
API, starting from an existing
starter project, and how you
can write moments for historical
moments that
occurred in your application.
And that field works
for all languages.
It's not PHP specific.
You can use that for anything.
Great.
GUS CLASS: New stuff.
So this wouldn't be Office Hours
without hanging out and
chatting with you guys.
So now, what have you
guys been up to with
the Hangouts API?
ALLEN FIRSTENBERG: I've got
a question first about the
[INAUDIBLE] start date.
What happens if you share that
historical moment publicly, or
to somebody else, or outside
of the history vault?
JENNY MURPHY: So sharing
moments.
The start date doesn't actually
impact the sharing of
the moments at all.
So right now, the way the
sharing works is you can share
individual moments with--
you can share back into your
stream by using the little
share control on the moment.
You can also change the
visibility on the Moments tab
on the profile by source,
which impacts all of the
moments that are in there,
including historical ones.
So if you were to go and you
were to dig into that panel
and, for example, set my Baking
Disasters app to be
visible to everyone on that tab
in the profile, then all
those historical moments that
got inserted would be visible.
Does that answer
your question?
ALLEN FIRSTENBERG: It
answers some of it
and raises some more.
So if we share it--
explicitly share it to the
stream, it will be shared with
today's date?
[INAUDIBLE].
JENNY MURPHY: Correct.
So the object in the stream
is the share itself.
FRASER CAIN: I've
got a question.
So what about the presentation
of the event in your stream?
Because obviously the way you
might present a song that you
listen to would be different
from a hike that you went on
or a recipe that you
baked today.
So how is the presentation
going to work for people?
JENNY MURPHY: That's
a great question.
GERWIN STURM: Is it actually--
JENNY MURPHY: Oh, yeah.
Right now, we're very focused
on getting the right API.
The way that you as developers
can get all those details into
our system--
we're very focused on making
that easy to use and awesome.
We haven't really thought
as much about the
rest of that part.
How those render in the stream,
when they're shared,
and all that other
kind of stuff.
This is one reason we're in
developer preview now, because
we want to focus on getting
the developer part really
great first.
And we are spending a lot of
time figuring out what that
looks like.
But it's too early to
say exactly what
it will look like.
Right now, as you can see, it's
pretty simple flat view
for all moments that get shared
to the stream, with a
link referring to the domain
that inserted that moment.
Did you have anything
to add, Gerwin?
GERWIN STURM: Yeah, no.
You answered it.
But my question was, so the
biggest limitation, in my
opinion, for the History
API is that you need a
public URL to share.
So the way I've been working
around it is that I construct
the URL with query parameters to
construct necessary snippet
information for me.
But the question is, you have
this result field which you
allow for some types.
And the question is if there
couldn't be done more with
that sort of information.
That you actually put all your
information you want to share
in this moment into the result
and not an object URL.
JENNY MURPHY: Yeah, that's
a really good point.
And we know that's going to be--
having a public URL is
kind of a big limitation.
For example, if you're a mobile
application developer,
you may not have any
web infrastructure.
And this is feedback we've
heard from you guys.
We're still working on it.
I don't have anything
to say about it now.
It's going to be cool,
and we're definitely
thinking about it.
And it's something that we
know we need to resolve.
ABRAHAM: Is there is a
corresponding end date with
the start date?
JENNY MURPHY: Is there a
corresponding end date with
the start date?
No.
So right now, there's
only one date
associated with the moment.
I guess because we think of it
as a moment in history, like
the start of a party versus
the entire party.
So it's kind of a single
point on the timeline.
ABRAHAM: Gotcha.
JENNY MURPHY: But that's
a good point.
Are there use cases you have in
mind where you might want
to use as start and
an end date?
ABRAHAM: I mean, theoretically,
if you're
having, say, a honeymoon
that lasts over a week.
And if you look at a specific
day within that week, that
honeymoon should probably
be listed on that date.
Even though with the current
implementation, if you only
implemented the start date, it
would only show up on the
first date.
JENNY MURPHY: That's a
really good point.
So for longer events.
Yeah.
GUS CLASS: So yeah, definitely
for things like, if you have a
party and the party ends
at a certain time, you
can create the event.
Not necessarily for the moment,
but maybe some forward
looking, forward thinking things
that I guess we're
talking about here.
Also we just got some questions
in from YouTube.
JENNY MURPHY: Cool.
GUS CLASS: And which is kind of
a good, nice, gentle way to
remind everyone that
this is live.
And we will try our best to get
to them as they come in.
So the first question
is going to be--
and sorry if I'm interrupting
your answer here.
Are History events signed
by the application ID?
So can you create moments and
then pull them back later to
verify their authenticity?
For something like, let's
say there's an
achievement in an app.
Or can they just be
created by anyone?
JENNY MURPHY: It's
a good question.
So are you asking--
I think I understand your
question is, so moments that
get inserted are definitely tied
back to the application.
We haven't thought a lot
about making moments
cryptographically secure and
signed and that kind of stuff.
Because the user can see those
moments, and then the user is
the one who shares those moments
explicitly with their
stream, the users that
they care about.
We haven't really put a lot of
thought into potentially
gaming or abusing the system
in this kind of way.
It's something we'll
keep in mind.
But we have thought a little bit
about getting a feedback
loop on moments.
Right now, the History
API is write only.
And you can use the debug flag
to see data coming back.
But it's kind of slow.
So not much of a feedback
loop yet.
But this is an interesting
idea.
GUS CLASS: Yep.
And so there's another one that
is, will I be able to
change the people I share
the moments with
after I post them?
So this is actually something
that people have been talking
about a good amount lately too
where let's say you have a
Circle and you want to share
with that Circle.
But you want to authenticate--
not necessarily that you'd
want to authenticate, but
would you be able to control
through Circles who you share
these moments with
as they come in?
JENNY MURPHY: So when moments
are shared to the stream, they
work just like any other post
that you make to Google+.
So you can't change
the security
settings on the post itself.
But changing downstream, like
changing the members of the
Circle can impact the visibility
of that post.
GUS CLASS: Cool.
Ooh, we got some more.
JENNY MURPHY: Great.
So before we dive into those, if
you're watching on YouTube
or on the Google+ page,
you can ask
questions at either location.
We're watching both.
But feel free to ask your
question at either location.
We'll keep an eye out for it.
FRASER CAIN: What method are
you using to watch both?
Are you using the Comment
Tracker, or have you got
something [INAUDIBLE]?
GUS CLASS: We want to be using
Comment Tracker, but it's
neither actually.
It's just kind of me clicking
as fast as I can.
So there's another question.
Can the user ignore moments from
the same app or reduce
their frequency on
a per app basis?
I guess someone's asking, will
Google aggregate moments for
people from apps?
Interesting idea.
JENNY MURPHY: Another
interesting idea.
So I guess one of the cases you
might be worried about is,
say there's an application that
produces a lot of moments.
So like, as you're hiking,
you're running, so you're
passing a lot of landmarks.
And our theoretical hiking
application might be writing
tens, hundreds of moments
to your history.
And we want to make sure the
interface stays useful.
Is this something we
care a lot about?
I don't really have much to say
on how it works, or how
it's going to work.
Right now, moments of the same
type, the same action--
so an add activity or a watch
activity or view activity--
will aggregate based on that.
But we're putting a lot of
thought into what other kinds
of aggregations we can do to
make sure that that interface
stays useful no matter how
you're using it, and no matter
how application developers are
using the History API.
GERWIN STURM: Yeah, I noticed
you're actually also
aggregating based on
the time frame.
So when I'm using
[? Songtrack ?]
[? MC ?], I've been listening
to music.
From 10:00 to 12:00, I've been
listening to those songs.
And then later, when I start it
again, I've been listening
to other songs from 3:00 to
5:00, even if there's no other
activity in between.
So actually have some time
frames in there as well in the
aggregation.
At least from what I've seen.
JENNY MURPHY: Yes.
We are also, right now, balling
them together a little
bit by time.
So if they occur in a cluster,
you'll also see them kind of
compressed into that cluster.
Just to make sure that your
different sessions--
so if you go on one hike and
then you drive across town and
go on another, those would still
be usable separately.
But these are just
the beginning.
If you have other ideas out
there of how you want to see
these interfaces work, please
send us this feedback.
This is a really great
opportunity for all of you
developers out there.
Because developer preview,
that's what this is about.
It's about us getting your
feedback while you get to bang
on it in real time.
GERWIN STURM: So I've
got a question.
Can we use the start
date in the future?
So can we pre-date moments, or
do you catch this in the API?
Just curious.
JENNY MURPHY: Future moments.
Think of all the potential
for that.
I see potential for trouble.
It isn't--
GERWIN STURM: I'm just wondering
if you allow it at
the moment, if it's possible.
JENNY MURPHY: I haven't
actually tried it.
We probably shouldn't
allow it.
So I'll be trying it
right after this to
find out what happens.
ALLEN FIRSTENBERG: I can see
applications for having events
in the future.
FRASER CAIN: Yeah, isn't
that the events?
ALLEN FIRSTENBERG: Well,
now I have an alarm.
I can now use it as
an alarm system.
JENNY MURPHY: That's
interesting.
FRASER CAIN: For my
future history.
JENNY MURPHY: But if your
cellphone dies and your alarm
never goes off, isn't that
moment like a lie then?
ALLEN FIRSTENBERG: Well,
then I could use it as
a dead man's switch.
That if I don't kill the moment
at some point in the
future, everyone's going to
know that I'm not killing
[? them. ?]
FRASER CAIN: You can still say
you were reminded in the
future, whether or not you
actually got that reminder.
And then after now, it
becomes history.
But at least the system
tried to remind you.
JENNY MURPHY: I'll be
trying to wrap my
head around that one.
That's definitely an
interesting case.
GUS CLASS: So we have some--
this is all moments
in the future.
But actually, there's
some more questions
coming in on YouTube.
A lot of them are
around grouping.
And one of them is, will I be
able to sign moments with a
marker ID and have
them collated?
On the user side is
a single story.
And then, kind of related is,
if I can specify some
sort of group ID.
From the context of my
application, that could be a
useful point of aggregation.
So it sounds like there's
interest in giving hints to
the History API around that
moments could be aggregated.
This sounds to me, actually,
like really good input.
But I do not know of any kind
of automatic way that Google
is currently doing
that on our side.
Jenny?
JENNY MURPHY: Right.
So this is a really cool idea.
I like this one a lot.
Keep this stuff coming.
GUS CLASS: Yeah,
keep it coming.
JENNY MURPHY: Right now, one way
you can kind of hint to us
that something similar
is going on is
if that target URL--
going back yet again to that
hiking application.
If that hiking application was
tracking my progress through a
hike, I may be targeting that
same hike page over and over
and over again as
I move along.
That's an example of one kind of
hint that exists right now.
But giving other hints to us
about the kind of cohesiveness
of activities is a really,
really cool idea.
And we'll definitely
[? bubble ?] that up.
GUS CLASS: Very cool.
Yeah, I can definitely see how
the microformat stuff would
kind of start to build up on top
of a [? page ?], and you
could actually start using, as
you describe, all of this
stuff added on to--
I guess the larger story,
to use the words
from Emily in YouTube.
And it's an interesting idea.
JENNY MURPHY: Very cool.
So are there any other questions
on the stream or in
the channel or in the Hangout?
GUS CLASS: We'll try
to keep looking.
But I'm not seeing on
the event right now.
And looks like we're getting
through most of them.
ABRAHAM: Is there any word on
the bug involving scope
conflicts being fixed yet?
JENNY MURPHY: Is there any
word on the scope?
So right now, the issue that
you're mentioning is that the
History API only works with
Plus.me and History right now.
You can't use any other scopes,
which kind of limits
your ability to use this API
with, for example, Google
Drive, for example,
or other ones.
There is a workaround.
It's not the prettiest
workaround.
What you can do is you can
send the user through two
authentication flows, and make
those API calls separately
through different instances
of the client libraries.
I realize this is a really
cumbersome workaround.
We're working on a solution.
It's one of those things
we want to
make sure we get right.
And we are actively
working on it.
But that's all I can
say right now.
ABRAHAM: No current change
in status, basically.
JENNY MURPHY: There is no
current change in status.
I have my eye on that
open issue.
So if you want to learn when
this issue updates, you can go
into our public issue
tracker, which I'll
link in the show notes.
And you can star any issues
that are relevant to you.
And you'll be notified when we
update them, when we fix those
problems, or when we have
other news to report.
So that's the best way to stay
up to date on these things.
GUS CLASS: Cool.
So looks like the questions
are trickling
down a little bit.
JENNY MURPHY: Well, great
stuff so far.
GUS CLASS: Yeah, really
great stuff.
Thank you everyone who
asked questions
in the YouTube comments.
It's always exciting to
hear what people are
interested in doing.
JENNY MURPHY: Any other
questions or
comments from the Hangout?
FRASER CAIN: It may shock you
and surprise you, but I'm
actually running out of things
I need to ask for anymore.
JENNY MURPHY: Wow.
FRASER CAIN: Yeah.
We're getting to the point now
where anything we can imagine,
we're actually able to do.
So yeah.
So now I guess all the
onus is back on me.
JENNY MURPHY: So write awesome
stuff and tell us what we're
doing wrong to make that hard.
And we'll fix it and
make it easy.
And then you can do
more awesome.
If that made any sense.
GUS CLASS: Yeah.
JENNY MURPHY: More awesome.
That's the important part.
GUS CLASS: More awesome
always makes sense.
Because everything must
constantly be
getting more awesomer.
JENNY MURPHY: More awesomer
is better.
GUS CLASS: Yeah.
GERWIN STURM: So you probably
can't tell us, but is there
any estimated time
frame [INAUDIBLE]
when the Google Play services
for the mobile [INAUDIBLE]
Google+ platform will
be available?
Because they've been announced
for quite a while now.
JENNY MURPHY: That's actually
information
that I do not know.
I'm very excited about it.
If I knew, I probably wouldn't
be able to tell you.
But I don't actually know.
But I'm eagerly awaiting
it just like you.
It's going to be
pretty awesome.
GERWIN STURM: Yeah, because I
think the History API for
mobile, it's a huge use case.
Because if you, say you're on
a hike, then you want your
geolocation from your phone.
So you would need it on
your phone to work.
GUS CLASS: Yeah.
The mobile scenarios
are huge for it.
And the kind of things
that you can get
from there are important.
But I believe the server side
flow could enable certain
mobile scenarios.
Is that right, Jenny?
JENNY MURPHY: It could,
potentially.
So if your users already
authenticated server side, you
can use your mobile application
interfaced with
your server-side software to
then write the moments from
server side.
Or if your user is authenticated
even device
side, you could even send them
the moments from the mobile
device using the
same REST APIs.
It's just not as clean
as it should be.
GUS CLASS: There aren't
exactly the mobile
starters right now.
Or they're not necessarily
working yet.
But yeah, it's completely
possible to implement it with
the REST APIs or doing
it server side.
JENNY MURPHY: Yeah.
In other words, we're also
very excited about it.
GUS CLASS: Yes.
FRASER CAIN: I know you don't
like to talk about
availability.
But do you know if and when
people will be able to connect
to a Hangout on air using
a mobile device?
JENNY MURPHY: Connect to hang
on air from a mobile device.
That's something I definitely
do not know.
But you know--
FRASER CAIN: It's not
permitted right now.
It fails if you attempt to
connect with a mobile device.
But you can imagine.
I mean, you want to
report on a riot.
You send a person out with their
iPhone into a crowd, and
they can be reporting
on the scene.
Right now, it's not possible.
JENNY MURPHY: That would
be pretty cool.
ALLEN FIRSTENBERG: The related
question is, any word on if
and when the Hangout
API will be
available on mobile devices?
JENNY MURPHY: Again, that
would be really cool.
No idea when.
Yes.
But we will be having more
Hangout Office Hours coming up
with cool Hangout stuff.
GUS CLASS: Yep.
JENNY MURPHY: Not
that, though.
Cool.
So any other wants or needs
before we wrap up?
Or any other questions
from the rest of
the developer community?
GUS CLASS: So there is one
for moments in History.
JENNY MURPHY: Awesome.
GUS CLASS: If I could define my
own unique ID for History,
could I correct that
moment later?
So can you make changes without
collation happening?
JENNY MURPHY: Ah.
This is a great question.
Right now, we have something
similar to an ID.
Certain moments that are written
to the History have a
result attribute.
Those results refer to a URL in
addition to the target URL.
So a case of this would be, for
example, I comment on a
blog entry.
The target of that moment is
the blog entry, but that
comment also exists.
What if that comment changes?
What you can do right
now is you can
resubmit the same moment.
And as long as the result URL
for that comment is the same,
you can update the values
in that moment.
And we're researching other
ways that we can support
updating existing moments.
For example, by allowing you
to submit your own ID.
Or maybe using IDs on our
side that we return.
This is stuff that I've
seen a lot of
discussion about on threads.
And I've actually talked a
little bit about it on some
Google+ threads.
So yes.
We're thinking about it.
We're still kicking it around.
Right now, you can do it
for moments that have a
result by their URL.
Maybe more later.
But we're still researching
it out.
See, we're thinking alike
out there, all of you
developers and us.
I'm glad to hear we're
on the same page.
So keep the feedback coming.
It's working really well.
Great.
So if there are no other
questions here, I guess we'll
wrap it up for the day.
So we got a ton of great
feedback today.
And please keep it coming.
You can do it outside of
the Office Hours too.
You can find us on Google+.
We have a Plus page, which you
may be watching this video
from right now.
Google+ Developers on Google+.
We watch [? stack ?] overflow
on the Google+ tag.
We have an official forum,
even a chat room.
Feel free to reach out to us
via whatever channel you're
comfortable with, and talk to us
about your experiences with
the History API and how you
think we can make it better.
And if you're just getting
started, I'm going to be
posting all of the code and
links to all of the other
material in the show notes, as
well as some links to some
videos that go into the History
API in a little bit
more detail that we either
previously covered or that we
talked about at Google I/O. So
check the notes at the end of
the show, and you'll see
everything you need to get
started there.
GUS CLASS: And you can also find
the latest documentation
on developers.google.com/+.
The symbol, not the spelled-out
version.
JENNY MURPHY: Correct.
Great.
So thanks so much
for tuning in.
Thanks so much for watching.
And thanks so much for the great
questions and feedback.
And we'll be seeing you next
week on the next session of
the Google+ Platform
Office Hours.
Bye.